any update on the top show watch and  find out they weren't kidding  because loopholes talk show is  officially here check out the first look  [Applause]  that's what this show is all about  spread and love it starts with loving  yourself cuz if you can't love yourself  I know you're gonna know somebody I  gotta get a minute for you the show  simply called RuPaul debuts on Fox TV  stations it's this summer for a limited  three-week run oh yeah in a statement to  etu who Paul says quote now more than  ever before we need a global voice that  will help everyday people navigate this  unique time in history not only do I  want to be a part of that conversation I  want to help facilitate and it starts  with you and it starts right here right  now RuPaul last hosted his own talk show  in the late 90s oh my god do I look like  the only freak in the world or what it  was on vh1 which is of course now home  to his other show RuPaul's Drag Race  [Music]  [Music]